julien carvelli médecin en soins
intensifs à l'hôpital de la timone à
marseille
bonjour je viens carvelli merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
les personnes âgées sont de plus en plus
menacé un second santé publique france
vous sur le terrain qu'est ce que vous
constatez ces chiffres vous paraît-il
être en adéquation avec ce que vous
vivez à la timone tout à fait on a plus
en plus de personnes âgées avec des
antécédents nombreux et donc de plus en
plus de personnes grave avec un risque
en effet de voir la mortalité liées à la
copie de 10,9 augmenter dans les jours
et semaines qui viennent mais malgré
toutes les restriction ont été prises
ces dernières semaines ces derniers mois
comment est-ce que vous expliquer
l'augmentation des hospitalisations chez
les plus de 75 ans à écouter en fait on
va on a un virus qui diffuse dans la
population générale qui est à d'abord
diffusée chez les jeunes et qui là est
en train de diffuser chez des personnes
un petit peu plus âgés probablement dans
le cercle familial et dans l'entourage
proche c'est comme ça qu'on m'explique
alors à marseille toujours la croissance
et et de l'épidémie est là mais elle est
elle est pour mais maîtrisable et à
écouter exponentielle le couvre-feu qui
va donc être instaurée d'ici quelques
heures à ce qu'il peut inverser la
tendance selon vous on l'espère tous on
l'espère tous parce que voilà c'est une
contrainte économique majeur pour
beaucoup d'acteurs et on espère que tu
il améliore la situation dans les deux
trois semaines à venir et que ces
mesures restrictives puisse être un
petit peu allégés qu'on puisse ray 2d
sous peu un petit peu dans l'est dans
les semaines qui viennent pour les gens
en souffrent le moins possible selon un
sondage harris interactive récent 1 6 %
des français disent ne pas vouloir
respecter le couvre-feu et 16 %
déclarent vouloir faire des écarts
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
réfractaires
je répondrai que les mesures
restrictives sont là la décision
politique est prise et qu'il s'agit
maintenant d'un effort collectif il faut
que tout le monde prenne conscience
c'est à dire que lorsqu'on ne respecte
pas les mesures barrières et les mesures
restrictives imposées basse et
tous les gens qui sont impactés qui vont
souffrir d'autant plus est d'autant que
longtemps donc il faut que tout le monde
se serre les coudes pendant cette
période et plus les gens respecteront
les mesures barrières et les mesures
restrictives
puis la durée de réflexion sera courte
et moins les gens souffriront donc ça
paraît ça paraît logique et j'ai pas
tout le monde
tous ne se sauvera les coudes dans les
banlieues et damien à votre avis ce
qu'il faut prendre des mesures de
restriction spéciale pour les aînés on
vient de parler des chiffres
comment est-ce que les ai pas de fonds
aujourd'hui pour faire face aux courants
navires us pour protéger leurs
pensionnaires
alors comment les débats de fond
exactement je sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est clair qu'il faut prendre des
mesures supplémentaires pour les pour
les personnes âgées il faut être encore
plus vigilant soit sur quoi individuel
dans les cercles familiaux proches il
faut être très attentionné voilà sur se
protéger protéger nos aînés et il va
falloir être très vigilants dans les
faits l'avenir on le rappelle un plus de
30000 contamination lors des dernières
24 heures s'est pas forcément dire que
tout le monde va développer des
symptômes
par exemple le professeur toussaint
disait récemment sur sur ces news que
c'était une maladie 100 malades et de
l'autre côté on a par exemple le
professeur je vais lui qui disait
récemment sur rtl il faut commander
beaucoup de lits de réanimation il faut
vite parer au plus pressé de son de
cloche différent dans l'impression que
la communauté scientifique
et bien si pair avec également ces
mesures de restriction et se couvre feu
qui est installé des annonces souvent
divergentes contradictoire entre les
scientifiques et le gouvernement la
population française au final elle est
un petit peu perdues décontenancé
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous vous
répondez en tant qu' en tant que
scientifique par rapport à cette
population un peu perdue a pas vraiment
pollution toxique moi je vous répondrai
en temps que réanimateurs entend
cliniciens c'est là qu'on prend en
charge des patients ce qui n'est pas le
cas du professeur tous le croit en tout
cas et ne boit que
en tout cas à marseille début septembre
l'écart augmenté là actuellement la
croissance de l'épidémie est là alors
certes elle est exponentielle mais on a
de plus en plus de malades de plus en
plus de malades vulnérables avec nos
animations qui se remplissent on prend
en charge les patients qu'aux vide mais
les patients dans qu'ovide en souffrent
aussi puisqu'on diminue nos capacités en
lits non qu'ovide donc on espère quand
même que l'épidémie que l'épidémie
s'arrête et que moi j'invite tous les
gens à dire s'agit pas d'une maladie
grave à venir voir nos services de
réanimation pour s'en rendre compte
on a des patients graves dans des
patients ce qui pour nous mais nous
n'aurons pas trop parce qu'on arrive à
les prendre en charge et on a absolument
besoin de préserver toutes nos capacités
pour que ce soit le cas merci je viens
car venez d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin en soins intensifs à l'hôpital
de la timone à marseille